as we begin do you see what i see a man who
attempts to keep the commandments of god
from a sense of obligation merely because he's
required to do so will never enter into the joy of
obedience he does not obey when the requirements
of god are accounted a burden because they cut
across human inclination we may know that the
life is not a christian life true obedience
is the outworking of a principle within it springs
from the love of righteousness the love of the law
of god the essence of all righteousness is loyalty
to our redeemer this will lead us to the right
because it is right because right doing is
pleasing to god christ's object lessons page 97
paragraph three it's a privilege again
it always is for me to have this honor
this responsibility to bring to you the words
of life tremendous tremendous honor and i thank
god for it and i thank god for your interest in
the truth it is the truth alone that sanctifies
it is the truth that makes men and women free
error frees no one error binds error keeps people
in bondage it is truth that liberates people and
so i thank god for your interest in the truth and
the truth ultimately is in the very person of
jesus christ who refers to himself in john 14 6
as the way the truth and the life by the way in
1st john chapter 5 verse 6 the bible says the holy
spirit is truth and in deuteronomy 32 verse 4 god
is a god of truth and so god the father is truth
god the son is truth god the holy spirit is
truth the family of heaven is a family of truth
and in order for you and for me to indeed be
members of that heavenly family we must be people
who live by the truth john 4 23 and 24 jesus
says god is a spirit and they that worship him
must worship him in spirit and in truth and in
verse 23 jesus tells us god is looking for the
people who will worship him in spirit and in
truth he is looking right now at this earth
for those who are willing even at the cost and
sacrifice to worship him in spirit and in truth
and i pray that the lord will bless you and
intensify and increase your love for the truth
i particularly welcome anyone listening who is not
a seventh-day adventist i keep saying that with
every presentation i make and i mean it each time
i say it we are always honored by your presence
and i pray that god will bless you and enlighten
you bless your family particularly your children
and may you feel the urge from above excuse me to
fellowship with us again so thank you very much
our subject for today do you see what i see do you
see what i see before i plunge into that message
do three little favors for me they are
not commands they are polite requests
favor number one wherever you are preserve
reference because god does not change based on the
day of the week or the environmental circumstances
god is always god he is always holy he's always
righteous he's always sinless he's always all that
god is he is always that and so as we worship him
through the spoken word wherever you are do all
you can to preserve an atmosphere of reverence the
second favor i ask is that you pray for me while
i'm speaking wherever you are watching just say to
god lord put your words in that man's mouth that
request is based on jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9
which says then the lord put forth his hand and
touched my mouth and the lord said unto me behold
i have put my words in thy mouth and with all my
heart and soul i want god to put his words in my
mouth frequently once in a while i should say not
frequently i listen to television preachers and
i ask god i say to god father please silence
that person not by death but just silence the
person so the person ceases to spew all of that
false doctrine i want god to give me his words
because his words are life his words can
bring back your children into the church
the words of god can bring back your spouse
the words of god can change the attitude
of your dictatorial supervisor the words of
god can improve your health i want to speak
god's word so offer that prayer while i am
speaking favor number three think isaiah 1 18
come now let us reason together and i often say
we serve a god who is willing to reason with us
he's willing to listen and so as you listen to the
words of life think reason and the spirit of god
who is the spirit of truth will bless your mind
with understanding and with light let us pray now
father in heaven thank you their god for life with
all our trials and tribulations we are grateful
to be alive and i thank you for that i thank
you the father for the lives of the listeners
for the interest they have in the words of
life the word that created the universe the
word that healed the word by which christ
raised the dead we thank you for the
interest in your word blessed in their father with
a revelation of truth to transform their lives
and if there's someone listening gay god
who has not yet established a relationship
with you may this presentation of those to come
move that person to surrender his or her life
to the savior father in heaven if i
have offended you forgive me they god
and with your forgiveness grant me that power to
overcome and grant me the hatred for sin as jesus
hated sin put your words literally in my
mouth put your ideas in my mind and grant me
the humility of the savior that i may speak with
boldness but with compassion father in heaven
thank you for all those who watching wherever they
are in different countries bless those countries
father and if anyone listening has contracted the
coronavirus i ask you humbly and sincerely heal
that person father heal that person completely
and deliver that person for that dreaded infection
now their father accept this prayer accept
this service i ask in jesus name amen
let's learn something about god as we begin
do you see what i see and the reason why
it is necessary to know things about god the
bible says without faith it is impossible to
please god or to please him for he that cometh
unto god must believe that he is that he is what
well he is a lot of things he's long-suffering
he's patient he's merciful he is forgiving he
is gracious he is abundant in goodness and truth
he does not clear the guilty he does not punish
the innocent and much much more we must know who
god is and now we will look at an aspect of god
when god sent samuel to anoint a replacement for
saul because saul had been disobedient to the
word of god and let me immediately digress
a little bit on the point of disobedience
if there's one thing god wants
from you and one thing alone
it's obedience you may say love where love is mere
obedience is love in action what god wants from us
is obedience god told saul through samuel
in first samuel 15 3 now go and smite amalek
and utterly destroy all that
they have and spare them not
but slay both man and woman infant and
suckling oxen sheep camel and ass destroy
everything of the amalekite nation that's what
god told saul in verse 9 the bible says but saul
and the people spared a gag and the best of
the sheep and of the oxen and of the fatling
and the lamb and all that was good and would not
utterly destroy them so saul largely destroyed but
did not utterly destroy and god said utterly
destroy because of that god told samuel to tell
saul because thou has rejected the word of the
lord he hath also rejected thee from being king
in the book uh the patriots and prophets page
479 paragraph two ellen white writes these words
god shut moses out of canaan to teach a lesson
which should never be forgotten that he requires
exact obedience counsels for the church page
268 paragraph five she writes these words
the history of god's dealings with his people in
all ages shows that he demands exact obedience
this is a digression yes i'll get back
to what god is like but i found i felt
the urge to make this point god requires exact
obedience if god tells you through his word
to do this and this and this and this and this
please do this and this and this and this and this
if you read exodus chapter 25 all the way down to
chapter 40 of the book of exodus those chapters
contain all the details for the construction
of the tabernacle and all its furnishings and
everything connected with the tabernacle
including the clothes of the high priest
moses had to see to it that every detail of
those instructions was carried out to the
letter he could not vary in one detail or he would
have offended god chapter 25 to 40 16 chapters
if you count inclusively of details some of them
microscopic and moses did not have the liberty
to change one item of god's instructions my
listening friend when god tells us to do this
of that we we should do it exactly as god says the
bible says the seventh there is the sabbath of the
lord thy god not the first not the fourth not the
second the seventh god is a precise god he is an
exact god and god told samuel to tell saul destroy
the amalekites all of them he did not and because
of that god replaced him with david now having
ended that long digression we continue but let
me pray father in heaven continue to be with me
please as i go on with this message do you see
what i see in jesus name i pray amen in first
samuel 16 verse 6 and it came to pass when
they were come that he looked upon eliab and
said surely the lord's anointed is before him
samuel sent by god to anoint a replacement for
saul god sent him to bethlehem the dwelling place
of jesse the father of david jesse had eight sons
but he only brought seven to samuel and so samuel
looked at eliab and he said surely the lord's
anointed is before him he said that because he
looked at eliab on the outside in verse 7 but
the lord said to samuel look not on the height
on his countenance or on the height of his
stature because i have refused him for the
lord seeth not as man seeth for man looketh on the
outward appearance but god looketh on the heart
this is an aspect of god i wish to stress
god does not see things the way we see things
isaiah 55 8 denial for my thoughts are not your
thoughts neither are your ways my way set the lord
for as the heavens are higher than the
earth so are my ways higher than your
ways and my thoughts than your thoughts
here is what we have here is god here am i
god's way of thinking is vastly different
from mine as far as earth is from heaven and
that distance can only be measured by god i would
imagine if god thinks one way and i think another
in order for us to be on the same page
one of us has to change the way he thinks
let me say that again if god thinks one way
and i think another for us to see eye to
eye one of us has to change the way we think
the bible says in malachi 3 verse 6 i am
the lord i change not hebrews 13 verse 8
jesus christ the same yesterday today and forever
therefore the person who needs to change is i
i need to change in order to try to think the way
god thinks i need to see things through god's eyes
now i am giving this long introduction because i'm
coming to a point upon which there is great great
doubt within the church and christianity at large
many years ago i spoke to a colleague of mine at
a place where i worked at a medical school and
she was a christian i said to her do you believe
it is possible for the christian to arrive at
the place in his or her experience where that
person no longer sins and she said emphatically
no she said it is impossible for the christian
to arrive at the place where he or she no
longer sins you must sin from time to time
this was her response she actually looked mildly
shocked when i put the question to her listen to
these two quotations and let's reason together
as we continue do you see what i see because
the fact is god activated the gospel because he
saw something in us god saw possibilities in us
god is not one to waste time and waste resources
and misplace resources god saw something in us
and god activated put into place the plan
of salvation now listen to these words
from the servant of the lord education page 15
paragraph two education page 15 paragraph two
to restore in man the image of his maker to bring
him back to the perfection in which he was created
to promote the development of body and mind and
soul that the divine purpose in his creation might
be realized this was to be the work of redemption
this is the work of education the object of
education the great object of life now ellen
white is telling us that the plan of salvation
was to restore in us the original standard the
original perfection with which god made adam
misquotation christ object lessons page
69 paragraph one it is very well known
christ is waiting with longing desire
for the manifestation of himself
in his church when the character of christ
shall be perfectly reproduced in his people
then he will come to claim them as his own now
we have a chronology of events in that quotation
a sequence of events one thing must occur before
the other in order for action two to occur
action one must take place first what are the two
events what is the chronology listen to the words
again christ is waiting with longing desire for
the manifestation of himself in his people what is
the manifestation of himself a sinless character
what did jesus say to the scribes and pharisees
which of you convinceth me of sin what did he
say to his disciples in john 14 30 the prince
of this world cometh and hath nothing in me what
did the thief on the cross say to the other thief
this man hath done nothing amiss that character
must be reproduced in us and so the servant of the
lord says christ is waiting with longing desire
for the manifestation of himself in his church
when that suggests chronology sequence of
events when the character of christ shall be
perfectly reproduced in his people then he
will come to claim them as his own which means
before christ comes back there must
be the reproduction of his character
in his church not just in one person on this
continent one in that continent there must be
the character of christ perfectly reproduced in
a people living on the earth in the last days
which means that through the indwelling power of
jesus christ his spirit we can be brought to the
place through the indwelling power of the spirit
of christ and our effort let me say that again
through the indwelling power of jesus christ
spirit and our effort we can come to the place
where we are victorious over sin and the character
of christ is perfectly reproduced in us now
someone listening may say this man is promoting
righteousness by works i am not doing that simply
because i use the word effort listen to first john
1 verse 9 a verse with which we're all familiar if
we confess our sins who does that we do he is
faithful and just to forgive us our sins and
to cleanse us from all unrighteousness in other
words i have a part to play and god does his part
i must confess then god forgives if we confess
that's my action that's my part of the bargain
he is faithful and just to forgive so when i say
our effort plus god's power it is not our effort
that does it it is the power of god but the power
of god will not work in the absence of the effort
of the sinner to do what is right in the sight
of god the bible says in james chapter 4 verse 7
resist the devil who does that i do that you do
that but with what power peter tells us in first
peter chapter 5 verse 8 whom resists steadfast
in the faith what is the faith this is the faith
there must be an effort on the part of the
believer to conquer what did paul tell the
young man timothy in 1st timothy chapter 6 verse
12 fight the good fight of faith victory in christ
is not won by an osmotic process you don't learn
the bible by putting it under your pillow at night
there must be an effort jesus says come on to me
only that labor who does the coming i have to do
the coming in response to the gentle nudge of the
spirit of god the power of god plus our effort
victory over sin is god's desire for us and god's
goal and god clearly has seen that this will be
the reality in many many lives if god had seen
that no one would have accepted the gospel why
would god activate the gospel god has seen what
you and i sometimes do not say and god is saying
to us do you see in you what i see eloise tells us
when god saw men and women when christ saw men and
women he saw them as what they could be there are
people to there whose lives are headed norway fast
because they do not see anything in themselves but
there's a god in heaven looking down and he sees
in them what they do not see in themselves but
they need now to see things as god sees things god
sees that in you he can have a champion saul was a
killer of the early believers he then became paul
god saw in him a champion of the gospel a builder
of the early church now saul did not see that
until he collided with jesus christ on the road to
damascus and so god says to you unto me do you see
what i see let's take a look at two bible verses
well more than two before i do let me pray
dear god give me the right words i
ask again i can never ask too often
and the right sequence of thought in jesus name
i pray amen john 3 4 6 i use this in my prior
presentation that which is born of the flesh
is flesh and that which is born of the spirit
is spirit flesh is flesh spirit is spirit
conversion takes us from flesh to spirit
this is what nicodemus needed he needed to go from
flesh to spirit jesus is discussing conversion
that which is born of the flesh is flesh that's
how we come into this world that which is born
of the spirit by conversion is spirit romans 7 18
for i know that in me that is in my flesh dwelleth
no good thing there is nothing good in the
flesh let's look at what the flesh produces
galatians 5 reading from verse 9 our subject
do you see what i see and that's a question god
is asking you do you see what i see in you the
possibilities the potential that i see do you
see that galatians 5 reading from verse 19.
now the works of the flesh are manifest which are
these adultery fornication fornication uncleanness
lasciviousness idolatry witchcraft hatred variance
emulations wrath strife seditions heresies
envyings murders drunkenness revelings and such
like those are the productions of the flesh
verse 22 verse 23 but the fruit of the
spirit is love joy peace long-suffering
gentleness goodness faith meekness temperance
against such there is no law now there is a law
against adultery fornication uncleanness
lasciviousness idolatry witchcraft hatred
variants emulations wrath strife
seditions heresies envyings murders
drunkenness revelings and such like there is
a law against that there is no law against
love joy peace long suffering gentleness goodness
faith meekness temperance now if there is no law
against the fruits of the spirit we are dealing
with sinlessness because the law identifies sin
perhaps i did not say that clearly it's my
fault let me try again where there's no law
there's no transgression the law identifies sin
the law condemns sin paul under the guidance
of the spirit of god informs us there is no law
against love joy peace long-suffering gentleness
goodness faith meekness temperance there is no law
against that meaning these are qualities that meet
with the full approval of god because they are
expressions of god but the works of the flesh
there is a law against them the works of the
flesh represent sin the production of the flesh
the fruits of the spirit represent that which
pleases god and that which is produced in a man
or a woman when that person comes under the power
of the everlasting gospel of jesus christ and god
looks at you and god sees in you that your
life can be a source or a means whereby
love joy peace long suffering gentleness
goodness faith meekness temperance
are expressed by the indwelling power of the
spirit of christ my brothers and sisters listening
adam sinned and god threw him out of the garden
and ella white informs us that god took the garden
of eden up to heaven and it will come back down
when this world is remade even more magnificently
adorned than it was before adam sinned god
put him out because he committed one sin
one that's recorded one reason with me as i
frequently say if adam was put out of eden
for one sin can god admit you into eden with one
sin or even restored the answer is obviously no
if one sin led to the destruction or the
eviction of adam and accursed upon the
entire world listen to what god said to
adam in genesis 3 verse 17 and unto adam
he said because thou has hearkened unto the
voice of thy wife and has eaten of the tree
of which i commanded this saying thou shalt
not eat of it curse is the ground for thy sake
the ground did not simply mean the ground where
adam was standing the curse applied to the earth
the whole world was cursed because
of one sin christ came to die
virtually because of one sin
the instant adam sinned christ began to function
as a savior as soon as there was sin there was a
savior that's the reason why adam did not die
immediately as soon as there was sin christ
functioned immediately as mediated between god
and man now favor number three reason together
if one sin brought a curse on the
entire earth if one sin brought death
death did not come until the time of the
flood when those antediluvians were so
wicked death began when adam sinned one sin
i keep stressing now if this is the case
how can god allow someone into the new world
with one sin he cannot do that because one sin
would put the universe at risk again and god's
word cannot be broken iniquity shall not rise the
second time my brothers and my sisters the bible
clearly teaches that god requires of us total
victory over sin before we enter the
pearly gates total victory over sin
in romans chapter eight reading from verse one
we continue do you see what i see god sees in
you someone who can reflect his character do you
see that god sees in you someone can be who can
be a blessing to your society do you see that
god seizing you someone who can take the gospel
somewhere in the world do you see that god sees
in you someone who is a living breathing example
of victory over the strongest addictions do
you see that do you see what i see says god
romans 8 reading from verse 1. and i read
from the king james version of the bible
there is therefore now no condemnation to them
which are in christ jesus who walked not after
the flesh but after the spirit for the law of the
spirit of life in christ jesus hath made me free
from the law of sin and death for what the law
could not do in that it was weak through the flesh
god sending his own son in the likeness
of sinful flesh and for sin condemned sin
in the flesh it is not necessary to live a life
of sin despite the presence of this weak nature
let me repeat christ by living a victorious
life condemns sin and his example for us is this
with your nature i lived a victorious
life you can do the same through faith
in me he condemned sin in the flesh that the
righteousness of the law might be fulfilled in
us who walk not after the flesh but after the
spirit now the righteousness of the law has no sin
the law of god points out sin but the law of god
has no sin if the righteousness of the law the
sinless law is fulfilled in a person that person
is living a victorious life because there is no
law in the sin and so the bible says christ came
one of his purposes was that the righteousness
of the law might be fulfilled in us who walk not
after the flesh but after the spirit now listen
to verse 5 of romans 8 for they that are after the
flesh do mind the things of the flesh there that
are after the spirit the things of the spirit for
sakes for to be carnally minded is death but to be
spiritually minded is life and peace verse 5 again
they that are after the flesh the unconverted
those who have rejected god who have not
yet come to him or rejected him they're
still led and driven propelled by the flesh
and the impulses and the urges of the flesh
their mind is set on the things of the flesh
that's why the saint paul tells us in colossians 3
from verse 1 if he then be risen with christ seek
those things which are above and there's nothing
of the flesh above in the sense of sin there is
nothing of the flesh above if he then be risen
with christ seek those things which are above
put your mind on that which is from above the
things of god set your affections on things above
not on things of the earth and so he or she who
is in the flesh the person mines the things of
the flesh when peter told christ be it far
unto thee lord this shall not be unto thee
when christ said i have to go to jerusalem
and die and suffer many things and rise the
third day peter rebuked him matthew 16 21-23
jesus said to peter get thee behind me satan
for thou art an offense unto me and here's
why for thou severus the things that be of men
not the things that be of god the word severus
there is same thing as set your affection on
things above the mind of peter was on a secular
deliverance from roman bondage and because of that
he was virtually functioning in the flesh he
tried without knowing it to sabotage the gospel
his mind was on the flesh the things of the
flesh and so paul tells us they that are of
the flesh do mind the things of the flesh they
that are of the spirit the things of the spirit
for to be carnally minded is death but to be
spiritually minded is life and peace through
the power of the gospel of christ my listening
friend every sin in the life can be conquered and
you and i can be brought notice i said be brought
we don't walk there of our own volition you and
i in cooperation with the spirit of christ can
be brought to the place where we are victorious
every over every known sin even and we refuse to
sin even at the risk of loss of life do you see
what i see says god do you see in you someone who
can be a jewel in the hands of god to display to
the watching universe we need to understand
that the ultimate purpose of the gospel is
not simply to deliver us from the condemnation of
sin the glory of god is involved the glory of god
is always highest and so the day will come
when every knee shall bow and every tongue
shall confess that jesus christ is lord to the
glory of the father the glory of the father
and the glory of the son are all involved in our
obedience to god's law in our victory over sin
the ultimate benefit is and perhaps benefit is not
the best word but the ultimate benefit is the fact
that god will be seen in the universe as just
and right and that satan had always been wrong
victory over sin is promised to
us if we will connect ourselves
with christ let's look at the
flesh again and the spirit
sinners sin naturally let me say that again
sinners sin naturally we do what comes natural
sinners there's a story with which you're
very familiar but i'll tell it nonetheless
of a scorpion and a crocodile the crocodile was
sunbathing on the banks of a river somewhere where
crocodiles dwell and the scorpion came up to him
and said listen i need to get across that river
but i can't swim take me over the crocodile
said if i take you over you'll sting me i'll
die the croc the scorpion said no i won't do that
that would be very ungrateful i won't sting you
trust me take me over the crocodile said no
the scorpion persisted the crocodile relented
and he said okay jump on he jumped on the
crocodile began to snake his way across the river
in the middle of the river where it was deepest
and the water was most violent the scorpion stung
the crocodile and he began to sing he was about
to drown and he swiveled his head and looked
back on the scorpion riding his back and said
why did you sting me now both of us will drown
and the scorpion said what do you mean why did
i sting you that's what scorpions do i stung
you because i am a scorpion sinner's sin those
who don't know christ because they're sinners
the flesh produces sin let me
say it more harshly this way
when we put a kettle on the stove to boil kettles
have a sort of a vent and the steam comes out
if there's no vent that kettle will
explode from the pressure when within
are you following me there is a vent through which
the steam escapes to release the eternal pressure
if a sinner is placed in an environment where
that person cannot sin a sinner unconverted
the person will explode because the urge
to sin cannot be repressed he mustn't
she must sin so that person would implode or
explode sin is a force the sin cannot resist
by himself so the citizens naturally now
when that person now goes from the flesh
to the spirit we must conclude that a genuine
conversion will create in that person a natural
desire to do what is right as verily as the flesh
creates a natural desire to do what is wrong
hey let me try that again i'm
not sure i made it clear enough
outside of christ a sinner will sin whether
in behavior in thought or in speech a sinner
outside of christ must sin
unconverted not under the control of the spirit
of christ must sin then someone truly converted
will just as instinctively
want to do what is right
you have to ask the question
here's the power of sin here's
the power of righteousness which is more powerful
here is the power of sin here is the power
of righteousness which is more powerful
if the power of sin leads the sinner to sin
the sinner who does not know christ whose
life is not controlled by the spirit of god that
person must sin that person sins instinctively
automatically reflexively genetically now that
person comes to christ and there is a genuine
conversion let me stress this a genuine
conversion where christ now by the spirit
possesses the mind and the soul and the will and
the heart of that person that person's urges now
are changed and the person can say as is said
of christ i delight to do thy will o my god yea
thy law is within my heart what am i trying to
say as naturally as the flesh sins so naturally
will the spirit and the person do what is right
the genuinely converted person his or her desire
will be to do what is right as instinctively
as the sinner's desire is to do what is wrong
the question then must be
asked are we truly converted
or are we simply improved no one will enter
heaven's gates who is merely improved because
improvement does not require the involvement of
the spirit of god conversion does transformation
does not all change is transformation there
are people who have stopped bad habits with
no help from god without acknowledging christ they
have changed bad habits but to change the nature
to experience a change of genes at the spiritual
level that requires the work of the spirit of god
through the reception of the spirit-filled world
and when that happens that person will do right as
naturally as an unconverted person does wrong in
medical ministry on ministry of healing page 491
paragraph three ellen white writes these
words listen carefully that which at first
seems difficult by constant repetition grows easy
and right thoughts and actions become habitual
as sin is habitual for the sinner right thoughts
and actions can be habitual for the saint
that which at first seems difficult yes we grow
in grace we know that but making a mistake is
not the same thing as sinning instinctively the
truly converted person desires to do what's right
and may slip because he or she is learning
how to carry out that urge but right
thoughts and actions can become habitual
through constant repetition as verily as
sin is habitual for the flesh right doing can
be habitual for the person who is genuinely
converted because the power to do right is greater
than the power to do wrong i'll say that again
but i'll say differently the power
of christ exceeds the power of satan
and i want you to believe that yes satan is
powerful blessed not glorify his power he
is powerful yes but the weakest sinner
on his or her knees satan is no match
for a weak sinner on his or her knees because
that person is empowered and sustained by the
divine power of the life of christ the power to
do right which is the power of christ exceeds the
power to do wrong which is the power of the devil
what am i saying when someone is truly converted
that person receives the very mind of jesus
let's talk about the mind of jesus in a few
minutes i have left let me pray again
father in heaven be with me now as i
come down to the end of this presentation do
you see what i see in jesus name i pray amen
here is what i mean by genuinely converted listen
to paul the holy ghost is telling him what to say
let this mind be in you which was also in christ
jesus that's not from revelation that's literal
you and i to conquer sin must have the
mind of christ not a mind similar to his
similarity is not sameness let me say it again
similarity is not sameness we must have the same
mind that christ had with which he conquered
because we're dealing with the same power
that opposed him the power of the devil let this
mind be in you which was also in christ jesus
let's go to second peter chapter one we read verse
four whereby are given unto us exceeding great and
precious promises that by these you might escape
the pollution which is in the world through lust
and by that by those promises we may
be partakers of the divine nature
whereby are given to us exceeding
great and precious promises
that by these we escape the pollutions and we
become partakers of the divine nature philippians
tells us we must have the mind of christ peter
tells us we must be partakers of the divine nature
and hebrews chapter 12 10 tells us that
we might be partakers of his holiness
the holiness of god must be ours we must
partic partake of the very divine nature
of god we can never be god and we partake of
the nature of god when christ enters into us
through his spirit and the spirit-filled word
and we live by that word empowered by the spirit
we partake of the divine nature of god because
the power in the vine is the power in the branch
and we must have the holiness of god first peter
1 15 be holy in all manner of conversation verse
16 says because it is written be holy because i
the lord am holy my listening friend total victory
over sin is not simply possible it is required
for admission into the kingdom of god because
one sin brought a curse on the entire earth one
sin introduced death the last enemy that shall
be destroyed first corinthians 15 26 if one sin
can do that then one sin will do it again in the
new world if god permitted and you want to enter
with one sin one sin is a very dangerous thing you
don't need two sins in the life or three or four
or five the practice of one sin is sufficient as
verily as the kingdom of heaven is like a grain
of mustard seed which becomes a tree the kingdom
of satan is like a grain of mustard seed that
also becomes a tree if it is not dealt with
do you see what i see this is god asking
you and god is telling you personally
through his word i see in you someone victorious
over laziness in your academic work in school
if you're a young person watching this and
god says to you or someone else i see in you
someone victorious over cigarettes who is now
encouraging others to move towards that victory
i see in you says god someone in whom the
character of christ is reflected so that
others are brought to jesus by observing
you i see in you says god so many things
that put a smile on the face of god do you see
what i see the bible tells us in isaiah 45 22
look unto me and be saved all the ends
of the earth look to christ not to you
that's not a command it's a brotherly
recommendation look to christ
not to you look to christ not your addiction look
to christ not your weakness why is that i'll pray
one more time dear god i'm closing i really
am close with me i pray in jesus name amen
but we all with open face beholding us in
the glass the glory of the lord i changed
into the same image from glory to glory even as
by the spirit of the lord the glory of god is
this character by beholding the bible teaches
us we become changed that's a principle that
cannot be broken by beholding we become change
now jesus says in isaiah 45 22 the whole bible
is the word of christ look unto me in other words
behold me when you behold me you see strength you
see victory you see power you see love you see
forgiveness you see forbearance you see long
suffering you see gentleness you see unrestricted
generosity when you look at me if you look at you
you see pride you see stinginess you see smoking
you see drugs you see lying you see laziness you
see theft you see working on sabbath you see time
stealing you see all of that if you look at you
and by beholding we become changed many of us
we never break from where we are because we keep
looking at us the bible says look at me look at
god look unto me says jesus christ in isaiah 45 22
and you will see power you will see victory look
to me because by beholding we become changed don't
keep looking at your circumstances i am not saying
ignore them but look to god when jehoshaphat was
attacked or about to be attacked by three armies
second chronicles chapter 20 he prayed in verse
12 of that chapter oh our god will thou not
judge them for we have no might against this
great company that cometh against us neither
nor we what to do but our eyes are upon thee
by looking at god jehoshaphat was looking at power
he was looking at supreme military strategy that
required an army to be led by a choir no human
being can understand that but god does not think
the way we think jehoshaphat looked at the source
of deliverance he did not look at his weakness
and i'm saying to you today god says do you see
what i see as god looks at you you look at god
god looks at you he sees someone in need he
sees someone with potential you look at god
and you see power you see victory you see a
divine enabling for your life from day to day
do you see what i see says god oh may the spirit
of god bring you to the place where you say father
i'm trying to see as you see i invite you in the
name of jesus christ lift your eyes look at jesus
you will see victory over sin
you will see trust in the father
you will see a love of the word you
will see love for enemies you will see
someone who did not respond to violence and
taunt and insult this is what you will see and
by beholding that will change you take your
eyes off yourself and by looking at jesus
you will see what you can become you will see
what god requires of you and what god requires
of you and me is exactly the life jesus lived on
this earth in our human form let me say it again
when you look at christ you are looking at you
can be by the power of god you cannot be god
but you can be all that jesus was in his humanity
elohim writes the desire of ages 664 paragraph
four jesus revealed no qualities exercise no
powers that men may not have through faith in him
he revealed no qualities exercise no powers
that men may not have through faith in him
the powers exercised by christ in
his humanity dependent on the father
is what's possible for you and for me but notice
the quotation says if they will be in subjection
to god as he was let me just rephrase that if
they will look to god as steadfastly as jesus did
right where you are without moving physically let
all the movement take place in your mind recommit
your life to god ask god to fill your heart with
hatred for sin this is how god described his son
in hebrews 1 9 thou hast love righteousness and
hated iniquity ask god to give you that ask god
to give you a love for righteousness because the
love for righteousness automatically produces a
hatred for sin ask god to give you a love for your
enemies ask god to give you a love for the study
of his word ask god to give you a love for that
which is spiritual and a dislike for the things of
this world ask god to do that and god will do it
let's borrow heads now as we pray father in heaven
we thank you for the challenge of your word but
god with the aid of the spirit we can understand
all you will have us to understand father in
heaven help your people those whom you love
because in a certain sense we're all your people
in a certain sense the cross of christ is for the
whole world there's someone listening to me
that god who feels he or she cannot overcome
he or she cannot enjoy the fruits of victory
reach that person their god through your spirit
and let that person know that you see in him or
in her a jewel let that person answer the question
father do you see potential in me and you will
say yes father do you see in me the possibility of
victory over my besetting sin and you will say yes
did god help that person touch that person to your
spirit that through that person's converted life
you may have one more living argument that the
charges of satan were false bless all those who
listened a double blessing on all our guests and
a special blessing on all the young children who
listen father keep us faithful and help us to see
as you see so that when you say to us do you see
what i see we can say yes i see it in jesus and my
eyes are on my savior thank you for loving
us dear god save us when you come where we
will dwell in the land wherein dwelleth
righteousness we pray in jesus name amen